I'd like to ask you why at the age of 40
did you start making films and then the
second question why did you choose Joe
McCarthy as your first topic well those
are two entirely separate questions so
let me deal with question one first
I'd been basically uninterested in film
because I see I saw film in my early
life as essentially a commercial
enterprise the films were made to make
money films were made to avoid the
reality of life documentaries like
Flaherty's Louisiana story were
fraudulent they presented a false
picture and I did I saw no space for me
in that world and then the New York
scene changed and it changed film in a
very precise and E Hollywood way and
this began with the film the Jack
Kerouac wrote called pull my Daisy it it
featured a great number of major artists
like Robert Frank the cinematographer
like Alfred Leslie the painter like a
great actress
Delphine se rig who went on to become a
star in France a great singer Anita
Alice and they were all in this film
it's very off beat made for very little
money and it's absolutely the
quintessential expression of The Beat
Generation and I thought if these people
can make a film for almost nothing and
it's one of the best films made maybe
it's time for me to look at what should
be done did you have background in film
at that time I I think most successful
people in the arts begin in innocence I
had no background which means that I had
no garbage to get rid of noted treatise
to get rid of I mean all that stuff
that's taught in film school is simply
taught so that you junk it at some point
and there was nothing I wanted from
Hollywood except to junk what that had
been so I went directly to a thing that
had never been done before in this
country which is a
I was able to buy from ABC the complete
army McCarthy hearings 188 hours now
this was one of the great and most
important political moments in American
life because when McCarthy began those
hearings when the government began the
hearings with McCarthy in April of 1954
McCarthy was high he was riding high he
had he was the most prominent and
powerful figure in American politics he
had changed the nature of American
politics he had said you're a communist
and even if you were as indeed he did
even if you were a cleaning woman in the
State Department and you didn't even
know what the word communism meant you
were a communist because McCarthy called
you one and the word communist was used
blatantly without consideration without
judicious necessity to condemn all kinds
of people most of whom were not
communist by the time the hearings were
over and for the first time you had a
hearing in which a demagogue like
McCarthy was exposed to all of the
American people the audience's for those
hearings were huge bigger than World
Series games really huge audiences and
at the time the hearings were over
McCarthy was finished he was no longer a
political entity now I wanted to take
all that raw material and it's not a
question of editing or reducing it's a
question of making something for
creating a structure of making a film
that had never been made before I named
it point of order because that heard
those that's phrase those words were
heard throughout America for months
point of order point of order
and all was disorder of course and that
was the film I ask you this now CBS and
Edward are murrow's expose on
McCarthy did that come before or after
your documentary before and it was thin
stuff right and don't forget Murrow was
on TV every week and he waited until
that endpoint to do his short indecisive
piece on McCarthy ah his was a basically
journalistic response where his mind was
an attempt to do something else which
was to make art out of political raw
material to make art to make a political
art which did not happen in this country
it was tried in the theater Orson Welles
did one of the first ones in the Great
Depression it was tried in the theater
under WPA political art was made but not
film and film was too dangerous because
it reached too many people so political
films were not encouraged pseudo
political films were encouraged like mr.
Smith goes to Washington all those early
classics but films that were really
about what is politics who runs the
country how do they run it to what end
I don't think that really happened until
point of order the what distinguished
point of order from other documentaries
in terms of style well the one thing
that bothered me more than anything else
particularly about sleazy Network
documentaries is that they always
depended on some idiotic narrator
Cronkite somebody who knew nothing about
the subject who would simply read off a
teleprompter I wanted to destroy that
voice I wanted the people who themselves
were in the film to be the only voices
heard so I began point of order with my
voice over black leader and I say for 59
seconds everything you were about to see
actually happened and I go on in that
vein for 50 seconds more and then I'm
out and there's no other voice heard
except those people who really were part
of that historical moment obviously he
wanted to show his downfall
so you had to pick some moments in the
hearings that would in a
fact shall reveal McCarthy unraveling
what moments do you think are most
striking well I think the most emotional
moment in the most dramatic moment and
the most dramatic the most emotional
emotional are not necessarily the most
political but it's something that
happened before the hearings began that
then burst towards the end of the
hearings Roy Cohn who was McCarthy's
assistant had a problem he beat the
draft so they all agreed that Cohn's
military record would never be mentioned
and just as the hearings were about to
begin
Welsh the famous Boston lawyer who
opposed McCarthy learned that a young
man on his staff had been a member of a
fairly communist organization when he
was a young person at the Harvard Law
School it was the National Lawyers Guild
so they agreed that nothing would be
mentioned about the National Lawyers
Guild now McCarthy was reckless McCarthy
could have really made something much
wilder than he ever dreamed of but he
was so reckless he destroyed himself
right on TV because he brought up the
name of that young lawyer at that point
Welch began those great speeches that
began sir have you at long last no sense
of decency
at long last no sense of decency and the
American people heard that and they
heard it unanimously and the Senate
heard it and the first time for the
first time the Senate which had
grovelled and crawl before McCarthy
stood up and passed even after the
hearings were over over passed a motion
of censure it was his its what the
Greeks called in their tragedy hubris
that overweening irrational pride that
brings you down brings you to
destruction and this is precisely what
brought it wasn't the good guys who
brought him down McCarthy brought
himself down and who do you think the
hero or heroes of the Makar
the army here in do you think it was
Welsh the Senators or perhaps television
itself really Doug I wish you wouldn't
give me the whole answer because there's
no doubt in my mind that it is it was
the the camera and the sound it was
television that was the hero
I mean Welsh was a great lawyer and a
highly sympathetic figure
but he too finally was a hired gun as
most great lawyers are the more money
you have in our society in any other
society I suppose the better chance you
have of hiring a great lawyer which
means a lawyer with a great fee and
beating the case but what really
destroyed McCarthy was that camera that
camera that's looking at me now and
which looked at McCarthy over a very
long period of time
when you multiply the number of hours
and the number of days from April
through through June of the Year 1954 it
was 188 hours that the American people
looked at him and nobody can hide in 188
hours in 188 hours if you're a good guy
it's revealed no matter how clever you
are or how much you want to hide even
being a good guy
and if you're a bad guy it's also
revealed and mccarthy was revealed in
the machine stripped him and he was
destroyed so you then chose to make a
film about the kennedy assassination has
your second film what led you into this
project well mark lane and I together
became involved in the film on Kennedy
Kennedy was a classmate of mine at
Harvard
I don't feel sentimental about my
classmates but I thought that Kennedy
was an important president and I think
he had an agenda that had to be stopped
and this is why we made the film because
we did not believe the Warren Report and
we thought somebody other than Lee
Harvey Oswald killed John Fitzgerald
Kennedy or at least that if Lee Harvey
Oswald had a row it was a minor role to
begin with Lee Harvey Oswald is a poor
shot in the second place
we now have so many facts and so much
proof about other people who are in
Dallas that day who had a real
commitment to the killing of Kennedy and
then as the political aspect of John F
Kennedy himself Kennedy had alienated a
good many people although he didn't do
very much but he spoke and he spoke very
convincingly about changing things in
regard to civil rights
this alienated a certain proportion of
the population but most importantly he
alienated the CIA because he did stop
the Bay of Pigs invasion in Cuba
and it is my belief that he was getting
ready to pull out of our tiny at that
point tiny presence in Vietnam he had
already withdrawn 1,000 troops and he
didn't think the war was winnable and
it's so he wasn't essentially an
idealist but a pragmatist and pragmatic
people are generally wiser than
ideologues like the right wing lunatics
who wanted the war in Vietnam and so he
had to be killed just as his brother had
to be killed
the most striking thing in looking at
the film today is the amount of
witnesses that you compiled interviews
with who claimed that they saw gunshots
or heard gunshots or gun smoke or
movements in this grassy knoll in his
fence which was very close to the
passage on the freeway where Kennedy
drove past witness after witness
confirmed that they think that that's
where the gunshot came from how are you
able to get these people on film and why
didn't the Warren Commission go after
him the extent that you did what the
Warren Report and Commission failed to
do makes you feel not only that it was
flawed but there must have to mean
something else afoot because we found
witnesses simple Texas working people
honest people who had no ax to grind who
were on top of the overpass Kennedy was
being driven down toward them they saw
what
and as well as anybody there were five
of them there the Warren Commission
interviewed SM Holland first he was the
foreman of these five people and his
testimony was so amazing in which he
said he believed that shots came from
the grassy knoll did not come from the
Book Depository building that there was
more than one shooter that there were
not three shots but four shots the
Warren committee Commission did not want
that testimony so it took a little bit
of the next man and none of the other
three nobody ever asked who the hell was
Ruby why was Ruby who was who was a pimp
who ran a cheap nightclub who was a drug
dealer why did he feel that it was a
patriotic duty to kill Oswald and then
when Earl Warren came with other members
of the Warren Report and they talked to
Ruby in his cell Ruby said mr. chief
justice
take me out of this cell take me to
Washington and I'll tell you the truth
this clearly implied he had not told the
truth and then Ruby died of cancer six
months later now doesn't it seem
reasonable to think that somebody put
Ruby up I mean this is an assumption
that had to be examined I'm not saying
it's the truth but it had to be examined
and weighed carefully and considered
isn't it at least reasonably possible
that Jack Ruby was said by one of his
bosses look you've got terminal cancer
go in and kill his son of a [ __ ]
and he will be comfortable in jail and
you'll die you're going to die anyway I
mean something like that maybe he said
it more kindly than I've put it but him
it could have been something like that
he was something the Warren Report had
it being efficient and honest would have
brought up question Wade and then thrown
out if they could prove it was not they
left too many strings lying around now
the other thing can you believe this
could anybody in his right mind believe
this that all the material they took in
the interviews with Oswald chief Fritz
chief investigative officer Dallas
police chief curry the chief in charge
of the whole that Police Department they
had no notes no record of any notes
now here you're interrogating if he's
guilty the most important criminal in
modern times the most important criminal
since the assassination of Lincoln at
any rate and they don't keep any notes I
mean you know that isn't feasible I mean
it makes the whole see any place where
you touch the Warren Report or what or
what the police did wherever you touch
it with a probing finger you knock it
out I mean could anybody believe ask any
honest cop ask any military policeman
ask anybody who's ever run a
courts-martial
or a judge's run a trial that if police
haven't aired a guy for eight hours and
who was killed the present United States
right there'd be no notes those two
people should be fired instead they
stayed on the force until they retired
the main point of your film rush to
judgment was to raise questions
concerning the Warren Commission's
theory that Lee Harvey Oswald was the
lone assassin assassin you punctured
many different holes in this theory but
you didn't really offer an alternative
hypothesis at this point in time many
years later do you have some ideas about
who you think might have been involved
in the assassination of John F Kennedy
well this is probably a better informed
than the Warren Report was but it's it
never I never pursued it I never did a
lot of work on it because I went on to
make other films I mean I covered what I
had to cover in the in the film rush to
judgment but I'm convinced that it was a
combination of Cubans and CIA people
Cubans under the direction of CIA people
Cuban veterans of the Bay of Pigs the
Cuban exiles Cuban exiles not Cubans
living in in Cuba today or then but the
same exile who attempted to overthrow
Castro in the Bay of Pigs operation
which Kennedy halted you know
those people believe to this day that if
he had put up the b-26s
and bombed the beaches and if he had
used more naval cover that they would
have won and it was at the last minute
that he called off the b-26 strikes and
those people hated John F Kennedy with a
passion and they hate him to this day
even though he's dead and it's
absolutely my belief that they with the
CIA officers who ran them together we're
responsible for the death of Kennedy do
you think the mob had any role Jack Ruby
obviously had mob connections he seemed
to be part of a conspiracy plot well I
hope you don't think this is a light
joke but it's my feeling you have enough
people at the ball without the Mafia I
mean it's possible that the Mafia was
involved and it's Pocket possible at the
market may even supplied weapons or
something but you have too many people
there and most of the evidence that
points there's a woman that Lane found
long after we made the film who had been
the mistress of Castro and then became
an a/d Castro person it was involved
with the Cuban community and she talks
of making a trip to Dallas with a Cuban
guy who was involved with the CIA even
in Watergate and Lane says before the
court and he won this case by the way
landed what what was in the car besides
you people and he said she said all the
trunk was full of high-powered rifles it
was Marita Lorenz right yes exactly and
that's you know why didn't it work
I mean if Lane could find that person
why I'm you know if a civil lawyer can
find that person where was where was the
FBI where were the investigators in the
Warren Commission Lane also alleged that
a Howard Hunt who later turned up in
Watergate and who had involvement with
CIA and he's right-wing Cubans is also
present in Dallas that day that's
absolutely true so is Richard Nixon
present in Dallas that day but nobody
think
he had anything to do with the death of
Kennedy that's something quite different
but didn't Mike Howard hunt was there
and Howard had lied about that right and
he lied in court about it and and this
all took this case ended only three
years ago well didn't Marita Lorenz say
that the caravan carrying rifles that
she was in was met in Dallas by hunt and
he was the one who received them and
then paid them off she did say that but
that was in spotlight right and
spotlight is not a paper is not the New
York Times I mean I try to be as
conservative as possible which is why I
didn't bring that up you brought it up
which I mean I'm glad you did because I
frankly believe it but you know it
doesn't have the same evident
evidentiary weight that the New York
Times has or the fact that hunt lost a
case in which he lied about where he was
it's one of the great mysteries and the
Warren Commission has been that belongs
to the garbage can of history and so
does the Warren Report and what will go
on is you know more and more people died
so there's less and less evidence but
people will go on asking that question
as long as people to ask questions let's
talk about your next film and the year
of the pig which was about the Vietnam
War and you made it while the war was
still going on
well I'm not only a leftist diamond
American patriot and it's very possible
to be a leftist and to be a patriot and
love your country and I that is a
position I take I thought our war was
immoral and so did many other people
and finally the majority of the American
people became to that belief but after
all I'm an artist I make films and I
wanted to make a film that would treat
history I didn't want to make an over
emotional film I didn't want to make a
piece of Hollywood nonsense like platoon
or I mean they came after my me anyway
but I wanted to make a film that would
place Vietnam in history beginning with
the French history which is where I
began
and a little allusion to the Japanese
invasion of Vietnam while we were in the
war with Japan and then our war
primarily our war and what it was that
our war was about why we were there and
as usual I use a collage collage method
in which many voices many faces many
images are used and that was the first
left-wing film nominated for an Academy
Award it was not widely played here
because it was very badly treated here
oh when it opened in Los Angeles
somebody broke into the theater and
wrote the word traitor on the wall I was
the traitor well that's bad for business
you know nobody knows nobody goes to a
film like the Booker the the people with
all the theaters canceled it and in
Texas when it was supposed to open at
Euston there were bomb threats so then
the University in Houston was going to
play it and then there were more threats
and then the ymh a in Houston actually
played it there's a big difference
economically critically and in every
other way from a theater to the Y Maj
what's the Y mhm a young men's Hebrew
Association oh like the YMCA except
Hebrew rather than Christian neither
Christian nor Hebrew has any particular
meaning for me I'm a non-believer but I
thought it was very brave of the ymh AAA
to do it but it's not the kind of
audience I would have had in a theater
but I I never complained about it and
I'm not complaining about it now if you
make hard films that oppose the
government you can't expect the
government to hand you a lollipop or
give you a tax deduction why I was
audited every year I mean I you know I
was audited every year because of what I
did I might as well have been a drug
smuggler or in the Mafia or something
because the film did uncommonly well in
Europe you know that's the but I wasn't
proud of that the French loved my film
they loved it for two reasons
a
France does have film culture and
they're wild about films that have new
forms and it played in three theaters in
Paris at once and got great reviews but
they also liked it because they had lost
the war in Vietnam and we were still
fighting it and they said haha
the Americans are fighting so they
enjoyed and I I was uncomfortable that
by that of course because I am an
American and not a French person I think
in the year the pig is probably the
densest and richest collection of images
of any documentary film that's ever been
made has probably never been so many
images before put together in a film
where did you find all of this material
and what led you to assemble it in the
way you did well I knew I could get all
the film in the West so I began by going
to Paris and meeting with the Vietnamese
and they gave me one film which was a
film made by them called the life of Ho
Chi Minh which was important and I used
quite a bit of that footage I then went
to Prague where the National Liberation
Front was and got material from Prague I
then went back to France and got French
material from the French experience in
Vietnam and I went to East Germany which
has one of the best film archives in the
world and got the Soviet material that
the Soviets wouldn't give me namely the
Soviet director Carmen's reconstruction
of the Battle of Jim BAMF ooh then I
came back to this country and got all of
the American footage I wanted by paying
three thousand dollars a minute for it
mm-hm
and then I shot a lot of material and
the shot material is the most important
part of the film because I shot a
deserter from the Green Berets I shot
the only man who I knew or anybody else
in the United States who spoke not only
in Vietnamese but Chomp and who was a
professor and a French professor who
taught at Yale and who taught Buddhism
and the history of Vietnam
and he he was a brilliant man who became
a friend of mine he's dead now but I
also then found American footage of
obviously of Johnson and McNamara and
their laws and protesters the one young
boy one young man I liked and admired
was a 19 year old who was a sergeant in
the Green Berets and who was deserting
and I helped him to desert he moved to
Sweden he still lives there all the rich
images and critical images of that film
which ones do you think best capture the
nature of the American involvement in
Vietnam you have some favorite scenes
are in the well I think that scene of
all those naval weapons being fired I
mean those monstrous it begins with it
that was the most desperate war this
country ever fought because the people
who fought that war were as badly
treated as we treated the Vietnamese
almost I mean you know they anybody who
wanted to get out of the draft who was
white could get out of it it was a war
in which there was an out of proportion
number of blacks of poor whites if you
were going to college you got out of it
so there was a class war in a sense I
mean the poor people who couldn't afford
to go to college went into the draft and
went to Vietnam and were killed and the
people at Harvard where I went to school
went to graduate school after being at
Harvard for the full four years they
then would go to law school or medical
school and add three more years and by
that time they were out of it the young
man who is Associate Producer and the
reason I helped wanted him to be
Associate Producer of my last film mr.
Hoover and I was somebody who avoided
the draft and went to prison he made a
principled stand against the draft and
he went to prison and his name is
Michael Thomas and he's a good friend of
mine he I found the faces of those
American generals the most striking and
you filled the screen with these
close-ups of Curtis LeMay and other
America's are Mark Clark who are making
the most brutal
and racist statements imaginal about how
the Orientals don't value life and about
how they should be bombed back to the
Stone Age and other horrible ly brutal
remarks what's the significance of their
faces filling up the image of the screen
well to begin with that I could say that
general LeMay was my own commanding
officer but but they get the point of
that that was during World War Two too
young you flew between the other ooh we
don't talk about that now but uh so
people people wonder about what law he
was Benton you're right do it LeMay was
my commanding officer and he did say but
bomb them back to the stone Age's that
there's a barbarism in that that you
don't find among civilized people the
thing that I cannot forgive my
government is that it never went back
when we finished our war with the Nazis
in the Japanese the very first thing we
did with the two richest and most
powerful countries in their own areas
was immediately helped to build them
back we poured billions of dollars into
Germany and Japan and when we were done
with the Vietnam War of course it was
because we lost it rather than winning
it but what we left was a legacy of more
bombs or unexploded that still killed
will kill people you see there's a kind
of cruelty in our view in our policy to
Vietnam that extends all these years
after the war it's sheer cruelty I mean
we took the Nazis and we helped rebuild
Germany and of course maybe because
they're yellow people because they're
Asians deter because we lost that war
because we admit that we made it Timmy
donut actually lost it we said all we
say we withdrew from it that we withdrew
because we lost it you don't withdraw if
you're winning I mean you were enable
officer you know that if you're winning
the other people withdraw you stay and
well big differences they not only do we
lose it but there were a socialist
country where as the Germans
Japan Japanese or capitalist countries
they were a communist country movie
about Richard Nixon was really really
you know one for the jugular vein but
funny a whole lot of different things
roll up into one well the proper title
is what I meant it to be most people
just call it Milhouse and I misspelled
his middle name excellent I spelled it
like the german word that his middle
name came from it was mu housing the
other great man whose family came from
Mill housing was Albert Schweitzer but
the name of the film is Milhouse : a
white comedy mm-hmm because to me Nixon
was the quintessential white comedian in
an independent sort of perverse sense
and I think that was the first time
anybody did the life of a president on
film and it's it's a full-length
biography it's a 97 minute biography on
film that goes back to his earliest days
and up until just before Watergate but
it's not a conventional biography in the
sense that you tell a linear story it's
rather like your Vietnam film a collage
of images that capture Nixon through the
juxtaposition of images in a very
complicated image construction well I
first of all I don't see film as being
linear to begin with you know it's to me
it's essentially much more disjunctive
much more episodic and I intentionally
made Nixon's life that way I mean one of
the themes I ran Nixon was always
nervous about who he was always nervous
and he wrote a book himself he had
somebody else write it but I mean his
name is on the book as the author and it
there his ideas surely it's a book
called six crises and it's an attempt at
his autobiography and he it's almost
biblical or religious in tone because
here he has these terrible crises and he
he overcomes them and he surmounts the
problem and then he goes on and upward
and upward until he becomes the
president
well some of those crises were flawed
you know I mean one of the first is the
his case Nixon's entire career depended
on what happened to Alger Hiss because
Nixon was an unknown Congress person and
he suddenly introduced the his case into
the house and it's a long story but
Alger Hiss eventually went to jail and
Nixon's career was made and somebody who
began in the Congress in the year 1946
is the most junior Congress person there
by 1952 was chosen by Eisenhower to run
as the vice presidential candidate and
it was because of the his case the his
case gave him a kind of publicity that
no Congress person of his generation had
day after day the his case played before
the American people in the different
courts and the courts of Appeal in the
Congress of the United States and Nixon
played it like a master these some
people say that Alger Hiss represented
really Franklin Roosevelt's New Deal and
a certain sophisticated internationalist
cosmopolitan mentality the people like
Richard Nixon and later Joseph McCarthy
would oppose so that by knocking hiss
off the right-wing was showing that it
could deal with the New Deal that it was
superior do you think there was
something on that there's a power
struggle going on between liberals and
conservatives and that hiss and Nixon
were just on different sides of this
battle at that time that's a very long
question you know Doug there's no doubt
that the the right-wing radicals wanted
to shoot down rose weld and shoot down
for instance Yalta and hiss was part of
the team at Yalta he was a state
department person who went to one of the
State Department people who went to
Yalta and the fact that he went to Yalta
I assume had something to do with the
reason that he was the one who was
triggered in a sense the contract was
put
on him it's clear from the evidence
that's come out since that time that
most of it was fairly phony and finally
the most ridiculous thing of all as I
say mr. Hoover and I is the fact that it
was found all the evidence was found the
microfilm was found in a pumpkin right I
mean who ever heard of anything as crazy
as that you know I mean here everybody
is looking for this vital evidence
that's found in a pumpkin in a farm in
New Jersey it's it's not really credible
you know in effect Nixon was a McCarthy
before McCarthy that the McCarthyism so
to speak began with Nixon going after
his I mean didn't McCarthy then start
going after the State Department to get
so-called communists out and begin his
crusade so there's a real linkage
between McCarthy and l'ainte Nixon here
there always was until until Nixon
became vice president then he had to
assume a different role because McCarthy
was a self-destruct kind of person and
Nixon was a very careful precise
ambitious man who would have done
anything and he did it but he also knew
when to be quiet and when he became the
vice president and then when the
hearings began two years after that
Nixon cut himself off from McCarthy
Nixon was always prudent some might say
the Nixon had no moral scruples frankly
that he did he did what he had to do but
if you look at it in a commie way which
I don't you could say he was a
pragmatist that he indeed did what had
to be done to further his career oh yes
there was all this big talk in the 1960
election about the new Nixon you know is
is he he's different from the way he
used to be he's more of a statesman now
I saw one columnist say there is no
Nixon Nixon was this back during the Red
Scare days he's trying to act like a
statesman now
Nixon is whatever is necessary at any
particular time the most pathetic thing
about Nixon is the one time he tried to
be a good guy he really got screwed what
was the head in the 1960 campaign that
was as tight as any election ever was
and now it's fairly clear that there is
no doubt that the state of Illinois was
the swing vote and the state of Illinois
was swung by voting many dead people all
of whom voted virginity all of whom
voted for Kennedy and the people on
Nixon's staff and important members of
the Congress said to Nixon start a
lawsuit and Nixon said no it would be
bad for the country let's let it go it
was so tight anyway that Nixon wasn't
sure he was going to win but actually as
you know if they proved only a few
hundred dead people voted then there'd
be enough of a scandal so that the whole
country would have been flawed at that
moment by as a result of that suit so
did Nixon did make his remarkable
comeback it looked like he was
completely out of politics you're
Milhouse film has that famous sequence
where he talked to the reporters in
California after losing the governor you
won't have Nixon to kick around my says
he says he's never going to run again
you know he says publish it do what you
want
he won't have next to kick around
anymore I won't be here I tell you no
from that minute on he was starting to
run again right
I mean Nixon never told the truth and
his his second attempt was brilliant
because he nobody in the world gave him
a chance and you have to admire that
stick to it stick-to-itiveness in Nixon
I despise the man I despise his policies
but that toughness and he's still that
way even after Watergate you know he is
still having people write books
defending the entire position of his his
administration I mean you can suddenly
think you can forget gordon Liddy and
all those crooks and thieves who are in
the White House and all that money
piling in
they're the plumbers the Cubans but
Nixon is there I think there are four
books now by Nixon not written by him
really but but his name down is the
writer since Watergate in 1974
he's a tough guy and I you know he can't
help but admire that as I say I despise
him but I also admire that never
quitting
Milhouse came out during the end of
Nixon's first term before he ran again
for reelection in 1972 how did the Nixon
administration and the public receive
your film Milhouse there wasn't a very
flattering portrait of Richard Nixon
well it was meant to be an absolutely
punishing and cruel portrait of a man
who himself punished and was cruel
nobody has found an error in that film I
mean everything that's in there is true
but it was a huge theatrical success and
then it was killed of course because I
was already a customer that the
government killed the film how'd they do
that
well the government doesn't do it
officially but it opened here in it
opened in New York in three main
theaters at one time the first
documentary ever it opened it was in the
plaza and another theater on 58th Street
and in The New Yorker all these are big
theaters in New Yorker at 900 seats and
then they were filled and the New York
ran run ran but when it went out to the
west coast it went into 50 theaters
supposed to go into 50 theaters and they
all canceled and that's the way hardball
is played and Nixon played hardball and
the manager the Bluebird theater in
Denver wrote me a long letter in which
he said we were going to play your film
Millhouse a white comedy and then we
were told by the people who own our
corporation that we would not play it
because the film did not give Nixon
equal time to finish with Milhouse's
with a no house story uh Nixon had me
put on the enemies list right
and that wasn't such a light thing
because it meant you were audited I was
already being audited anyway but I was
on the enemy's list and the enemy's list
was not a big bunch of bunch of people
it was people Nixon regarded as real
enemies and to me it was a badge of
honor of course and I still keep it as a
badge of honor I always have a few
Xeroxes of the enemies list in my the
drawer of my desk and I like to look at
them I mean that's just most sincere
form of film criticism when the
president the United States takes time
out to cut you off I mean that's real
you know that your work has a kind of
dimension that it was the Taylor films
don't have the after Milhouse what was
your next film project and what were you
feeling about film at that time having
all these films suppressed then it
wasn't a discouraging or well I made a
film whose title came from Robert Frost
called America's hard to say oh and that
was about the Chicago basically by the
1968 Chicago Convention and the fix and
the assassination of Bobby Kennedy and
it ends with a great speech I can say it
because it's not my speech by Arthur
Miller who says something the effect
that what we learned in 1968 is that the
people don't own anything the
politicians do and the people who own
the politicians they own the Democratic
National Convention they own who's going
to be elected who's going to be
nominated and all the rest of it that
was a film made in anger and were made
very quickly and then I went on to make
to begin then I went out to finish
painters painting which I had begun you
did a film on the Weather Underground
which was really unique can you tell us
about that well it was unique but most
of the people in the Weather Underground
one of the sad things we find if you've
lived among radicals as I have in I'm a
radical as you don't come they don't
come from the lower class you would
think that the lower class
which was treated punitive Lee would be
the class that would but in our society
for instance the Weather Underground who
made the strongest protest as the
Vietnam War started to wind down we're
essentially from the upper classes or
the middle classes and these people did
a tremendous number of bombings in which
they tried never to hurt anybody they
put a bomb in the State Department they
bombed police stations they bombed they
bombed my brother-in-law who was a CIA
person gracious and they bombed his
office they bombed all kinds of people
who were not people didn't bomb people
they bought all kinds of installations
which stood for military power which
stood for the war in Vietnam which stood
for injustice and the FBI went crazy
because they couldn't find these people
the FBI had hundreds of people full-time
looking for these guys and women there
were as many women who was already a
feminist group there were as many women
in it as men and so I thought why not
why don't I do this film why don't I go
underground and show the FBI how it's
done and you had to find him of course
it wasn't hard ha ha not for me I mean
it was hard for jig for the FBI but not
for me I just took a friend of mine
inside and said listen you know where
those people are ah put me in touch with
him so it began like a mystery story it
was wonderful because he said about a
week later he came by said ok they're
the Mayflower Hotel that's 59th Street
but it's an park where Central Park is
and he said go to the third phone booth
from the left at exactly 7 o'clock and
the phone will ring so I went in there
the phone rang and it disguised what he
said Dantonio I said yeah man said ah
you will get a message from us which
will tell you what the next step is so
the next step was it
I was to go on the subway which I never
take to be on the last train to get on
the train then jumper off quickly and
then make sure that the train left the
station obviously and get on the train
after that and take it to a certain
station in Brooklyn hell of long ride
and there would be a phone booth on the
northwest corner go to the phone booth
and at exactly 7 o'clock the phone would
ring phone racks said okay now walk
sorry I ended up and I thought the guy
who did this had military training this
is like the great field of fire you know
except this time it's vision because I
was standing in a corner I was visible
from there from there and a huge arc and
I was supposed to stand five minutes I
stood five minutes and out of the
darkness came this young guy and he
smiled in 2d and then he gave me his
fake name shook hands and he said go
over there there's a woman holding a
copy of Time magazine against her chest
like this and I did it so involved then
we went into a restaurant and sat and
talked they said that what you want to
make this film and the doom to them we
finally agreed and then I got Haskell
Wexler and they went to a safe house in
California and we went to the safe house
and film them and made the film and the
FBI went bananas and as a result we were
subpoenaed now the First Amendment the
Constitution is the dearest thing and
all law to me that is that that we as
Americans have the right to feel think
right film anything we want so I enjoyed
testing the First Amendment we got three
great lawyers in the entire Hollywood
community supported us we stood there
with our lawyers and I read my statement
which said I believe I have the right to
make any film I want to me that's as
clear an expression as there is of the
First Amendment in regard to film and
behind us stood Martin Sheen and Warren
Beatty and the head of the of the screen
Directors Guild and
50 well-known actors and the American
Civil Liberties Union and the FBI went
through the chart withdrew everything
and we won and we were the first people
in the history of film to win and that
year I got the award of the American
Civil Liberties Union for defense of the
First Amendment and I'm glad we did it
and it's a good film and it doesn't
advocate bombing because I make films
not bombs those people bombed my film
gets treatment that other films do when
I film I noticed that the Germans
brought it imported for a hell of a lot
of money tremendous amount of money that
this is going to be great they're going
to play on every station instead they
brought it to suppress it oh they
brought in a seven-year contract and
they never played it the young German
radical was writing a book about me
found out about this he wrote a big
story that was poached in every German
newspaper so that we got revenge down to
the last bone did the FBI step up its
activities and surveillance of you after
that yes they tried to break into my
house and then you know there are always
good people this is a great complex
country to young lawyers and the Justice
Department wrote me letters the same
they signed the same letters wrote a
letter saying we're resigning from the
Justice Department because of what it
does to people and you were among the
people and they said the FBI tried to
break into your house well the FBI did
this and this and this and these are the
people who were involved and here the
documents oh my god so it was pretty
great stuff and I never went probably
with that because I didn't want to hurt
them in spite of the fact they said they
didn't care but Antony knows I haven't
mentioned their name which I remember
very well but he was this the time where
you got your Freedom of Information Act
information on the extent of FBI
surveillance of you when did that come
about then
and you know that of that film alone
generated ten thousand documents I mean
it's not just ten thousand my whole life
that one film generated ten thousand
documents because as I say in mr. Hoover
9 an ex-fbi man came to see me he said
you know why you don't even have the
numbers for your files on the Weather
Underground I said no he said because
you're listed under Bernardine Dohrn you
see because she was one of the leading
Weather Underground people so what they
would do is they would put my file under
her file so when I say do you have a
file on me concerning my Weather
Underground film they could say no this
city much freedom or much information no
no that's the whole point it was very
very funny I mean you know you wanted to
go and shoot them but at the same time
you had to realize it was funny that I
mean you know these people are supposed
to be represented on order and they
stand for suppression and disorder the
Charter the FBI is a personal is a
there's a reasonable Charter the Charter
the FBI is to go after criminals is to
prevent crime across state lines like
bootleggers bank robbers etc but it's
not in the in the Constitution to be
used to keep people from making films or
writing books for having ideas the next
film I made was called in the King of
Prussia and I'm not I'm an atheist but I
have always admired Daniel and Philip
Berrigan because they were brave and of
what because of what they did they were
priests their priests one is a Jesuit
one was resigned from the priesthood as
married as children and runs it a house
in the middle of the black district of
Baltimore where anybody is welcome to
stay or be fed so they decided to attack
a thermonuclear nose cone at the General
Electric plant in King of Prussia
Pennsylvania and they did this and I
made a film about it and Martin Sheen
heard about it and I knew him anyway but
he said D I want to be in the film I'll
play any part you want me to play and I
said well it might had I could be the
judge he's the bad guy he said oh I'd
love to do that I'll be the judge so hit
Martin's the judge but not only was the
judge he said it must cost lot of money
to make that film I said well that's my
problem it does he said let me give you
some so instead of hanging of the action
the film he sent me a check for $10,000
and that filmed the film's changed
people's lives that film changed
Martin's life because Martin has now
been arrested seven or eight times in
demonstrations and he's now connected
with Mitch Snyder and the homeless
movement in Washington and his own
children think he's bananas you know
because he goes out and does it he's
middle-aged now he's forty eight or nine
he goes out and does all this stuff and
gets arrested and and he hadn't been
active in know all that Munoz out here
now do you politicize them I pose a lot
of people hmm establishment in the
ruling class in this country are very
much on the right track from their point
of view of suppressing and much of your
stuff is possible because you do
politicize and radicalize people that's
my intention after all isn't it I mean I
don't make these films as an academic
exercise radicalize all you do really is
show what what what the truth and truth
is reality truth is radical yeah the
truth is always radical reality is
radical reality is radical is absolutely
correct because if we knew if the
American people I believe enough in the
in America and the American people to
feel that if they knew what was really
going on say in Nicaragua not this
blather that Dan Rather puts out blather
rather but you know what really is
happening there there'd be a sense of
outrage about it
but we've already brainwashed on that
subject this is why your work is so
radical and subversive because the
official version of reality whether it's
the Kennedy assassination the Vietnam
War Nixon Nicaragua is lies its
distortions so if you counter that we
the truth you're coming off as a radical
subversive you're subverting the
official account
I'm very self-destructive the most
useful person to me in all the world is
Vincent Canby the New York Times he's
their chief film critic he gave no house
of review that guaranteed of the hit it
would be a hit in New York but I
attacked him anyway and it finished my
getting a review from the New York Times
but I attacked him on the question of of
actually El Salvador and and I ended my
letter by saying till not only am i
right and are you wrong but I challenge
you to have the entire staff of New York
Times go over any of my work and find
one place where I've tinkered with
tampered with history go find one and
then you can write about it and call me
a liar and he could not find one I mean
they're always tricks in film but
there's I mean they're cuts that are a
little faster than they should be or
something else perhaps but but there's
nothing as cooked in my work as was
cooked in the work of the United States
government during this whole period on
any one of the subjects I addressed then
I went on to finish painters painting
which I had begun and painters painting
is a film about people who were friends
of mine and political people never liked
the film because it was a celebration of
New York painting it started building
Kooning in Andy Warhol and jasper johns
and frank stella and robert rauschenberg
and and a great many painters and people
in the art world of New York and this
had never been done before you know just
think of what it would have been like
into to have lived in Paris and have a
camera crew and film Braque and Matisse
and Picasso and that's exactly the way
New York was safe from 1949 1952 the
time I filmed them in 1970 and on past
1970 by me I chose I was there actually
and I knew those people well I knew
Rauschenberg and John's before
they ever sold a painting a woman I used
to live with
he gave a Warhol his first job I knew
these people extremely well I met Frank
Stella when he was still a student at
Princeton and I knew de Kooning from
long before and Barnett Newman and most
of my political friends hate that art
and they hate the fact that these people
have all made millions and millions of
dollars I mean millions those people
make more than bank presidents do and
they're not even crooks so that I think
that nobody makes as much money in
America today including movie stars and
Jasper Johns he probably makes I know
that he sells about 10 paintings a year
for 800,000 H and then he sells some of
his older paintings for a lot of money
into your other work how do you see it
relation to your political films well
what I always said I was doing with my
films once I got a few of them made was
to try to put on film the history of my
time that interested me and the painting
of my time interests me and it's not
political the very the very world around
painting is essentially a reactionary
world it's a world of many millionaires
getting their kicks by buying paintings
it's a series of sharp dealers of hokey
museums but it's also done by people who
came from all sorts of classes most of
the painters I knew came from the poor
and they're now super millionaires it's
and I don't care about the money my you
know I mean even though I own some of
their works I don't care about the money
I like the work it's and as I told you
before I'm a patriot you know American
art was really strong and and new and
vital and interesting
and painting is always being for the
rich in the Middle Ages it was the
church that was rich you don't think
that peasants commissioned art in the
12th century was Cardinals and Pope's
kings and Lords painting anything that's
tactile we see the beauty about film is
its very nature should be democratic
that anybody can go into a theater and
look at it the beauty of the written
word is almost the same thing even
though books cost twenty dollars today
it's not really that serious but if you
want to buy a major Jasper Johns work
that's old you're going to have to lay
out ten million dollars and that
immediately takes most people out of the
market yes but it doesn't mean it's
necessarily that maybe the people who
buy those paintings are bad but the
people who make them are not political
art in the United States that people
made a lot of money on like we know down
to Mexico Wow you see these incredible
great political murals they realize
what's missing in the United States is
art that carefully control to keep out
the political art alright well let's put
it this way we've never had an artist of
quality who tried to do political art I
mean Ben Shawn was not art of quality
and Jack Levine is not an art equality
the Germans have produced political art
modern German art there's a guy called
Hans Hakka who is quite amazing he's
attacked Margaret Thatcher he's attacked
Reagan and he's done it brilliantly I've
seen Swedish political art too and I've
spent a lot of time in Sweden Saints
British political art but it's not as
good as German there is one man now who
is doing serious political art who's
making it a success but it's it's a
minority because frankly paint what is
what can be owned you can't own a film
basically except the cassette and you
can't own a book in the sense that you
own the rights of it but when you own a
painting you own the entire thing
nobody can reproduce it without your
permission it's yours and there's a kind
of ownership that says it and it
transcends the concept of bourgeois
society because it goes back as I say
the lordly societies and religious
societies the greatest collections of
old are in the world or by the Pope's
you can still go to Rome and see not
just Michelangelo's Chapel but see one
painting after another the ruling class
of always controlled art as a sign of
their temporal power absolutely and it
continues to this day it's the big
corporations that buy most of the modern
art for their corporate buildings or or
donate healthy or donate them to the
Museum of Modern Art and the major
museums around the country and get
healthy tax deductions and all it
painting has to do with money there's no
doubt about that
tell us about your film mr. Hoover and I
that really takes courage in this day
and age to attack the FBI directly I
believed enough in this country so that
I don't think it takes courage to attack
the FBI I've been attacking it all the
time but I I wanted to attack thee I
wanted to do something that never been
done before I went to tell my life story
and do it in terms of mr. Hoover the
head of the FBI and his interest in me
which began when I was 16 years old and
to make a film that would reflect the
bounce and the heat that existed between
the FBI and me from that time to the
present at 16 years of age he was a well
I mean he had every right to to have a
small interest in me because I was a
precocious person and I entered Harvard
at 16 which is fairly young to begin
with and then I joined three radical
groups I joined the young Communist
League I joined the John Reed society
John Reed was a Harvard graduate who
covered the Russian Revolution and
changed and I joined the American
Student Union which was like SDS was in
the 60s but that was a long time before
him and I think that the FBI should have
taken a file out on men and realized
that it was nonsense because I didn't do
anything basically I mean
wasn't old enough I wasn't political
enough I did it to find out I mean I
went to demonstrations and but there was
nothing too crazy I mean I this was the
1930s when the country was in a great
depression
I guess when there were hundreds of
thousands maybe a million's militant and
we were getting ready to go to war with
seven or a war in which I enlisted but
that's something else I mean there's no
doubt about that
but the FBI you see the real problem is
that the FBI is always being a secret
police force as I said before the FBI
does have a charter which is to go after
criminals but it doesn't have any
charter to go after thought to do
thought control or to care what
organizations I belong to if those
organizations break the law or if I
break the law then the FBI should come
after me but those organizations did not
break the law and neither did I that's
the significance of Hoover for you well
Hoover is the quintessential lying cold
warrior bureaucrat all of those things
are evil he's one of the truly most evil
people that our society has produced and
to me one of the most wildest things was
that Hoover even attacked gay people
when he himself was gay and nobody ever
had the courage to say this
he lived with Clyde Tolson as man and
wife for thirty of the years that he ran
the FBI and if somebody applied to the
FBI and was gay he would be rejected
because he was queer I know it's it's a
kind of theory of royalty that the King
can do no wrong King John Edgar and his
wife Clyde and his Queen Clyde can do no
wrong but anybody else bingo
Oh to me that is simply outrageous and
in fact you compiled some files on J
Edgar Hoover in your film you exposed
Hugh Hoover to public scrutiny in the
same way that he is to like to expose be
except I couldn't I can't hurt anybody
and what I was exposing was the truth
right and not secret files
those secret files were really really
crazy because they were so complete I
mean I enlisted to be a flyer and when I
was in flying school I mean this is
world war ii world war ii he corrupted
people he had people i don't know what
made them do it he did it with military
intelligence reporting of what I was
doing all the time when I was in the Air
Force and there I was flying expensive
equipment and these people were
reporting they had nothing to report cuz
I'm not an idiot I never talked Marxism
in the Air Force I mean he says I wanted
to be in it and all that and I was very
the only thing I did that that he didn't
care about only the local police cared
about
I was the Wing Commander of my class you
see this is drove the FBI crazy and two
other aviation cadets and I and we were
getting ready to graduate we we were in
Texas in that time the rice hotel which
is nothing I was the best hotel in
Houston it's as many years ago in 1943
we rented a big suite and we got drunk
and I used to have a knife and I took
the knife and split open the pillows and
all the feathers came out they didn't
have air conditioning those days they
had fans so I had the fans going with
the feathers fly and I said snow room
this is a snow room and we kept drinking
and feathers flying it was a really
serious offense because here's the
police department came in they think
that come on we're gonna have to take it
up to jail on the manager said you'll
have to take him to jail it'll affect
their careers all he was pay for it we
paid for the damage and got off but I
mean that was the the real crime of my
military career
there are also scenes in this movie of
your friend John Cage baking bread
speaking about his philosophy of
creativity and your wife Nancy giving
you a haircut one of the significance of
these sections of the film interspersed
with the more I listen well I consider
the John edgar Hoover elements non-human
and the other elements of the human
element I see my wife does cut my hair
because she does in real life I can't
stand going to barbers I don't know why
I mean maybe my brother was a
psychiatrist could tell me where my wife
was a psychoanalyst
but I can't stand having some guy want
to put smelly stuff in my hair and you
know like everything that John says it
sounds so simple so naive and it's
profound you know it's I wanted to be an
artist I didn't know which way to go and
he just says and we maintained this
relationship over many many years and
he's politically radical and that he
thinks that Thoreau was the greatest
American Thoreau who went to prison for
one day rather than pay rather than pay
his tax for an unjust war the Mexican
War t-this is raises an interesting
point about your film work as a whole
many people see you as a political
filmmaker making the documentaries the
political historical I am a political
right right
but in addition you're an artistic
filmmaker in other words art and
politics it's one thing I'm an artist
who makes political film okay so that's
the way you would see yourself yeah this
is sometimes neglected in analyses of
your work people fail to see the radical
innovations you've made in the
documentary film your use of it for
artistic statements visions your use for
a little look at even mr. Hoover and I
that's nobody's made a film like that I
mean I can't say that it's I don't think
it's that original but the fact that
nobody else did it must mean that it's
somewhat original I mean I made a film
about myself I'm not a particularly good
actor and I'm the main actor in the film
and it's it's not easy to talk for 89
minutes and my voice is on just about
the only voice in that film except for a
few words of Nancy's and of John's and I
know the film works is I've only shown
it about four times because I don't even
have a final release print or release
prints all I have our to answer prints
which are not correct and it played here
and you know how people applauded it was
remarkable the same thing has happened
every time it's played and people have
to reinvent themselves all the time and
a country has to be reinvented all the
time
and the idea of Liberty has to be fought
for and reinvented all the time and it's
exactly what we should be doing instead
of being repressive instead of having an
FBI that wonders what you read or what I
say or whom you go out with it should
worry about about who is breaking the
laws the real laws that should not be
broken and we should be making a new
kind of life in this country that isn't
for the rich because most of the people
in this country aren't the rich this is
not a world of George Bush's this is not
a sleazy world of the Reagan's this is a
world of many kinds of people from
different colors and races of different
national backgrounds all in one place
and it seems to me that we devolves on
us to be experimental to be radical to
be open to seek justice to risk our
lives for the truth and we're not doing
that and nobody's ever done that well do
you have done it I think I almost gave
no country is ever done no country but
individuals within this country I think
you just gave a remarkable statement of
what your life's work no I'm also a
hypocrite and a liar and it's you know
come on I'm a human being so I'm full of
error but the collective people of this
country interest me more than I am
interested in myself and I'm that may
sound like a lot but it isn't I mean the
idea of living in a country that would
change that way I mean I think the
Thomas Jefferson in spite of you can't
blame Jefferson for his his acts and
thoughts which were natural in his time
but I think that people like Jefferson
and Lincoln and Tom Paine in particular
and a good many other Americans have
stood for something that all the world
admired
and one of the things that rankles us
now is that nobody admires it because we
have nothing to hold up I mean you
really can imagine what imagine that
people would admire a country ruled by
Ronald Reagan and his wife it seems to
be unbelievable not credible and I think
you know I think one of the points of
all my work is it's directed to change
into changing the country and getting
young people in particular to believe
that it's possible to do tremendous
things things that require daring and
and and to make a new world I mean this
place was called the new world we're now
an old world you know we have lost our
ingenuity as well even even in the
business world that I don't care that
much about but we we were the new world
and we are now in every sense the old
countries Germany Japan countries long
before there was the United States are
the new world there are even more new
ideas in Germany now and so that's why I
make films you also it seems to me have
done quite a bit of reinventing
documentary I'm struck by how different
your films are every single film you
seem to approach from a new angle
there's always some innovative features
in it so I think as well as this
political aim of telling the truth and
exposing the lies and dealing with the
hard and controversial issues you really
have attempted to innovate the
documentary film to develop it in new
directions to make formal contributions
to the film and it's this intersection
of art and politics that I see is
defining your work as a whole and I
think they're related because art can be
emancipatory the notion of formal
innovation of invention of openness of
creativity of doing something new is an
analogue to political change it's the
same process I I agree with you I think
that I mean I think this is what my work
tries to be
and I there's no point in saying in
giving a speech like the one I just gave
and and making it and saying this is a
film because it isn't I mean a film is
something else if we were to could make
a film doing this with the TV cameras we
have to rethink the whole thing and
change the form around and it's it's a
very it's a very heavy problem so to
change the very nature of an interview
I'm looking into Lisa's camera and so I
mean I'm in this static position so the
only thing I can hope for is to say
something that's different or else pull
out a clown's hat and wear it or you
know something else but but I do think
that we always have to test I mean that
really is what the game is about and um
but okay what you're saying is actually
correct and I'm rambling because I mean
I could never stand to make the same
film over which is why I could never
work in Hollywood in Hollywood if you
make a really successful picture that
brings in a 50 million dollar profit you
know you have that guy with the claws
number four number five what is he the
guy that scratches kills the women Oh
Freddie or Freddie I mean those things
are not inventive they're not new
they're not exciting and they're dead
and we have to look for a new art and
that's why I liked painting frankly
because because it was an individual
enterprise and a painter could paint not
because he had to change it but because
he he had he had no alternative but not
because there was any demand in the
market I mean the painters were honest
in that sense they weren't changing the
way a tailor would change fashion for
clothing and
that's why one of the reasons I was
intrigued with the painters I found so
many people on the Left sterile when it
came to ideas about what art should be
her film should be or poetry should be
they were back at some other place the
already been explored and finished dug
up the evacuation was there an owl that
was already was a coffin the net needed
was a coffin a tombstone the ultimately
why did you choose then documentary as
your media of choice
he started off more interest in art
really you were very involved in the
arts and why was it that documentary
rather than fictional film or painting
or any number of other well first I
loved the document I loved but and the
second and equally important is frankly
money is that you could you could make a
work that was reasonable in price my
stuff isn't that cheap actually when you
put them all together I've spent a few
million dollars but that's for ten films
whereas a two million dollar film in
Hollywood is is not much I mean not
having to raise a lot of money or have a
lot of money is freedom it's a way to
make films or to make a make a work of
art that isn't produced by an account
well and puts surrounded by three
lawyers do you have any projects coming
up now are you working on anything
well the enthusiasm of other people and
in myself for this new film leads me to
think that I should make another film
and I'd like to make a film about
something I'd like to make a film about
some women I know who they are but I'd
like to make a film about women to see
if I could really understand what women
think that I don't think because I'm not
a woman and it would be political too
and one of the things I've liked about
my work in the past is that I've hired
so many women and got them in a position
where they could leave which is what I
always wanted them to do is they could
go and make their own work I like to
hire people who had no experience
because then they wouldn't have bad
ideas and some of them went on to become
phenomenally successful and some settled
for children and marriage and you know
life is life is composed of choice I I
don't like one more than the other I
mean they were all like children to me
in a sense other more questions no
that's it I won't thank you very well we
come to the end of the end thank you so
much for coming down
we showed I can't tell you how happy I
am to be here this is you know this is a
great reception and tremendous people
and it's not [ __ ] and you know the
response on the campus is terrific and I
feel I'm among friends here absolutely
thank you thank you so much